I started getting interested in science
actually when I was really little. I
liked to play this game with my parents
where I'd ask them a question, something
like, why is the grass green? And they
give me an answer and then I would ask
them, why? And they would give me an
answer and I'd ask them, okay why? I kept
wanting to dig down into exactly what it
was, you know, really figure out the
answer to my question on the most minute
level and so I think that science really
complements that and has a lot to do
with that, you know, you're never
satisfied with the answers you get, every
answer leads to more questions. In the
class that I'm taking right now, there's
quite a few women faculty members,
there's a good ratio of female students
to male students, in the class so that's
been really great, there's definitely
been a lot of really great mentors and a
lot of really inspirational peers that
I've met as well.
I think in the future
what I would love to be doing is in vitro fertilization and IVF, screen for
different genetic diseases or
potentially cure some of those genetic
diseases in embryos and improve people's
lives that way.
Whatever I do, if I do
decide to become a doctor, for example, I
know that because I got that
well-rounded education and that liberal
arts kind of point of view, I will be
better at doing whatever I end up doing
because I studied science at Harvard.